so we have two cylinders here and let's
say we know that they have the exact
same volume and that makes sense because
it looks like they have the same area of
their base and they have the same height
now what I'm going to do is start
cutting up this left cylinder here and
shifting things around so if I you just
cut it in two and take that bottom
cylinder that bottom half and shifted a
bit have I changed its volume well
clearly I have not changed its volume I
still have the same volume the combined
volume of both of these half cylinders I
could say are equal to the original
cylinder now what if I were to cut it up
even more so let me cut it up now into
three well once again I still haven't
changed my original volume it's still
the same volume as the original now I
just cut it up into thirds and if I
shift them around a little bit I'm not
changing the volume and I could keep
doing that I could cut it up into a
bunch of them notice this still has the
same original volume I've just cut it up
into a bunch of sections a bunch I've
cut it horizontally and now I'm just
shifting things around but that doesn't
change the volume and I can do it a
bunch of time this looks like some type
of poker chips or gambling chips where I
could have my original cylinder and now
I've cut it horizontally into a bunch of
these I guess you could say chips but
clearly it has the same combined volume
I can shift it around a bit
but it has the same volume and this
leads us to an interesting question and
it's actually a principle known as
cavaliere's
principle which is if I have two figures
that have the same height and at any
point along that height the
cross-sectional area is the same then
the two figures have the same volume now
how does what I just say apply to what's
going on here well clearly both of these
figures have the same height and then at
any point here wherever I did the cuts
at this point at the same point on this
original cylinder
well my cross-sectional area is going to
be the same because it's going to be the
same area as the base in the case of
this cylinder and so it meets
cavaliere's principle
but Cavaliers principles nothing exotic
it comes straight out of common sense I
can just do more cuts like this and you
can see that I have you could say more
continuous looking skewed cylinder but
this will have the same volume as our
original cylinder when I shift it around
like this it's not changing the volume
and that's not just true for cylinders I
could do the exact same argument with
some form of a prism
once again they had the same volume I
could shift I could cut the left one in
half and shift it around doesn't change
its volume I could cut it more and shift
those around still doesn't change the
volume so Cavalier ease principle seems
to make a lot of intuitive sense here if
I have two figures that have the same
height and at any point along that
height the cross-sectional area is the
same then the figures have the same
volume so these figures also have the
same volume and I could do it with
interesting things like say a pyramid
these two pyramids have the same volume
and if I were to cut the left pyramid
halfway along its height and shift the
bottom like this that doesn't change its
volume and I can keep doing that with
more and more cuts and because at any
point here these figures have the same
height and at any point on that height
the cross-sectional area is the same and
so they have the same volumes but once
again it is intuitive and it goes all
the way to the case where you have you
could view it as a continuous pyramid
right over here that has been skewed so
no matter how much you skew it it's
going to have the same volume as our
original pyramid because they have the
same height and the cross-sectional area
at any point in the height is going to
be the same we can actually do this with
any figure so these spheres have the
same volume I could cut the left one in
half halfway along its height and shift
it like this clearly I'm not changing
the volume and I could make more cuts
like that and clearly it has still the
same volume and this meets Cavaliers
principle because they have the same
same height and the cross-section at any
point along that height is going to be
the same so even though I can cut that
one up and I can shift it it looks like
a different type of object a different
type of thing but they have the same
height and the cross-sections at any
point are the same area so we have the
same volume which is a useful thing to
know not just to know the principle but
hopefully this video helps you gain some
of the intuition for why it makes
intuitive sense